9瑞基世津翁です皆さんたナッツって知ってますか
えっ高も3年くらい付き合ってるんですけど彼と僕の交仲良くなれたきっかけというか
共通点的な部分で
アニメとかアイドルとか戦友さんとかそういうのが好きみたいなのがあるんですよ
ここしばらく仲良くしてきた中で声優さんっていいにねっ
釈ちゃんとか化している声楽器なタイプなんですよ
ちょっと今日は彼を喜ばせようとふぺシャルゲストをお呼びしました
どうぞ
こんにちはー
足湯の膵臓湯デーエロ
人生は言えば抜けます
ちょっと今もあっつの科学にいるんでちょっと
オープニングが抜けを静かに行かせていただきたいと思います
家異論も生産対するんですよねぇー
オイルさんねうん
いく本当結構本当にもうちょっと来てくれるんですよね
小さいこぱにゃおっっていうかどれだけ怒ってねは知りたいと思いまして
ほんとそうですねなんだかみんなの片瀬示したばっかりですけど
優先ですねハッハーンっぽいというのが今回のキーワードになっているのです
とか声で芹沢さんっていうのがいかに早くわかるか
そしてシザーサンドといかに知っているかというのを国会ちょっと
確かめていければいいなと思いません
なんであの今近くにほんとすげーとこにいるんですけど
簡単に合わせませんそれで今回こちらで遊んでいきたいとおもいます
さあビって送る帰ってくる者れくりーこれですね色んな遊び方ができるんですけども
トランシーバー的な使い方もできるし自分の声を録音したり録音した声を別の諸比丘
と
できることができたりします救う
他にもいろんな遊び方があるんですけどもここでピッチとも買えるんですよ
あーそこが高い音が低いほど飛んできてなかなか高いよと低い音になるとか確かに
レーザーさんというのはわかりづらいと思うんですけども
次のでまずこうだんだんヒントを出すてってまずこの声の主が今朝はさんかどうかって
いうのを
わかるかどうか来てまず聞いて
いきます入ってそれ終わってから
レザーはさんに関するクイズを3つ出してもらいたいと思います
山門見事正解したらアイマスなんで失敗したら
finally です
ねっ簡単なのから徐々にてくれるんですね
そんな形ましょうかいやもうまず当て子やなぁ
青鯉ナンバー1っていう言葉があって世界で一番をチークは可愛いんだよみたいな感じ
でやってるんだん
ブーブー
というわけでサーモン徹底としましたシーザー何度こういう先に3つヒントとして録音
ストローク八尾今からやりましょう
見た入っ
よろしくお願いました
なってい
なあ井戸
は
わけないよなぁ
バーレー立ててよーおい
すっかーいえーい
次は高い声だよね若菜わかな
[音楽]
普通の声でいきますはーいそれじゃあ自己紹介行くよ
はぁ
でおい待て最初は好みってでたちがそれぞ予算的ず原則どうか確かめていきたいと
おもいます
で by こぼ結構ハイ当時わけで今
しゃべくるを3つここにセットしました猛虎に中だけ書いてあったんで
この通りやって果たしてた立は大好きな声優さんの声をつっ
どこ行っておりますよろしくお願いしますお願いしまーす
と呼ばれません
僕をスパッとちゃうしなぁ
これこれで振った立
誰かわかるかなピンクな再生ボタンの長押し
ここは電気とか絶対ながら良いてこれ
持っています
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
だれああ
誰
またそこから先です
ああああああ
女の人か女の人ペップはから完全にわからん
小浜字じゃわからんん
とっ
あーラブーアーマー遅れちゃったーーーー
動画
飛んだとですかわかったらこれある女性の音声をぶっこんしたそう
ものですの塔ですねちょっとずつこれ俺ですね
i love you ちゃーん
大
まぁ大抵じゃないえっ
国はいつでもどこでも間 future んと決まっ
うスーツって何です合格えんですかあっても舞うあっ待って
tujuh
ん
ですがまだ彼ば社名くるに別なさんの声が入って10分しか思ってないんでした持って
ないのでサビくるにはトランシーバーみたいに2人で会話できるものがあるんだよ
話してもらっていた
ん
何か分かった常に
芹澤優さんのお会い this というグループのご紹介
大
さすがにも誰だかは食ってるよねー
ねぇ
そっくりさんがこういうもんですねああ良い会社びっくりしちゃう
ないん
えっ
幅にもうられると思っていねえ
茶髪めちゃにやってますよえっ
そっくりさん
[音楽]
あありがとうござありがとうございます上辺地植えっ
これ録音されてるんですねでもネクタイの色はていようが良かったなぁ
嘘や営業って言うよをスライダー録音できるになる
[拍手]
くま時ごろくださでしょ
1回ちょっと変えてみる芹澤優さんの声真似かなんか
憧れているような人なんですかあなたはああ
p ああああ
じゃないよ
かわいいかわいいかわいいかわいいて前ってなんか会話できてません
まあこれわかんないならわーっ
あっというわけでたナッツよはい
実はいまこの建物の中に
シリーズを言うさんがいますいや嘘さては絶対に嘘
[音楽]
a
いねえやや開いたり
いっ
が次いで言ってんすかああ
へーそりゃ痛いですけど行き行ってみようですっ
1回会いたいですねー
クルーザー
うわぁ
いうわけでならずだはいここからされくるで製造さんから3本問題がきます
吸っていいギターこの3つに見事正解したら
で笹に顎類は俺あってらんないよそう
売れないんだよと言うけどせるぞーさん問題をお願いします
掃除ホッケーが担当
ています
じゃねーぜっこういう扱います
いやーす
はっはっは
は
[音楽]
たくさん1きた人いっ
殺させていただいて言うんですけど
ナンバーワンだ
因子が台詞暖房
ない言葉なんですよイースター大丈夫ですよああ
ああ
あってない人線1
あんなにもぐれすれば
[拍手]
英語だ富士
ni
はなれは
言葉はございません
ファーストスター first single カー
u & u っていう意味にあればまあ
買ったんですけど決算が消えてみる
ん
早い nd
ああああああ
ありがとうございます
主はすっと申します
[音楽]
あああああ起きたぞ
聞いてます
ユモンか
[音楽]
ん
3ボス米ツイッターのたよなぁあったその文字列
あなたかを文字列にた気がするんですけどね
つける以上いく web
悪いました
定価が予選
4日
[音楽]
twitter で見たっていますああああああああ
実ははいっ
[音楽]
は架空作用機序イラスト問題です
ん
人造石等が誕生して緊張してきた緊張していたません
の囲碁と思ってよね
愛しません
無駄ですねじゃあせる問題行ってきます
ああ
どうぞ
ana
[音楽]
ni
me
早い
プリマゆうちゃんが出てるから見た行
南美玲ちゃんめっ
ああっん
うわーん
うんいい
h
ああああああ
noa ん
スリープロードスタジオですね
プリパラをとっていたスタジオん
あああん
任務柄じゃありません
[音楽]
あーん
re too ん
yeah い
うんうん
じゃ7タイプん
ああああああ
まあまあままに来てくれハイパー
俺の
rar
ん
def
me
はいましたはいっ
[音楽]
たらっちっ
うわマジで可愛いやばあああーーーー
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
うううう
uh
せっかくなんだよはい何か好きな言葉でも録音してもらえなさいっ
えっ
いい感じにお願いします
ガッツように
プーおける自己んぬんか八号機て良いんじゃヤード某よ
田口お兄ちゃんっ
ありがとうございますありがとうございます
r
ああああああああああああっ
というサイクルですねこういう風録音できたり録音したものを他のサビ局に届けたり
他にもいろんな遊び方ができますのでぜひ皆さんしゃべくりで遊んでみてください
黒瀬内容は動画の概要欄にありますぜひホームページチェックしてみてください
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございまーす
どっちうわぁ
バッハ